[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions our phone lines are open if
you have a Bible related question give
us a call now at 800 God says that's 800
7297 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact in 1899 a New
York City taxi cab driver Jacob German
left his Mark in history by becoming the
first person in the United States to be
cited for speeding in an
automobile geran was a driver for the
electric vehicle company which leased
its cars to be used as taxis in the
bustling City the car that German was
driving was known as an
electrobaton in
1894 there were about 60 electr bats in
1899 operating as taxis in the New York
City area where speed limits for horses
in cars was 8 m an hour when traveling
straight and 4 M hour hour on a turn
German was traveling at the lightning
speed of 12 M an hour the officer who
pulled him over this Speed Demon was so
outraged he actually chased him down and
pulled him over with his bicycle and
arrested him and threw him in jail
overnight that's funny because you've
got someone getting a speeding ticket
for going 12 miles an hour and he gets
pulled over by a bicycle policemen I
wonder if he had red blue lights
flashing on his his
bike but you know it it makes me think
about just you look at the cities today
and if that was speeding and uh they
were worried about the the traffic back
then it makes me think of a prophecy now
naam is not specifically talking about
speeding cars but just listen to this
friends and the Book of naam you don't
hear that quoted very often one of the
Minor Prophets chapter
2:4 the Chariots rage in the streets
they jostle one another in the broad
roads they seem like torches they run
like lightning it sounds like La uh
around
Sundown I think he's actually talking
about the fall of Nineveh and the army
that came in but there is another
passage in Daniel 12:4 talking about the
last days and it said but you Daniel
shut up the words of this prophecy and
seal the book until the time of the end
many will run to and fro and knowledge
will
increase think how far we've gone Pastor
Ross in in just about a hundred years
from from that first speeding ticket to
uh artificial intelligence and
self-driving cars and uh people
tourism going to space and um Daniel
said in the last days knowledge will
increase and knowledge has increased
exponentially more in the last hundred
years than all of the history of man put
together which makes me think we're
living in the last days and that's
exciting because you know one of the
Prophecies of Jesus in Matthew CH 24:14
said the gospel of this Kingdom will be
preached in all the world for a witness
un the Nations and then the end will
come and um now with you know the
internet and um you know International
Communications and
satellites um there's scarcely a place
we can go in the world now where you
can't connect and hear the gospel in
almost any language you know Pastor Doug
that reminds me of well an experience
you had in Papa new Guinea way out in
the bush you and the team it's actually
makes me smile to think of it you and
the team were out there and you're
looking for a native house just kind of
a grass roof kind of Hut thing and you
found the perfect spot and you were
going to do an amazing fact and you
walked up to the house and you asked the
person if if you could film in front of
the house and the lady knew who you were
who you were because she was watching it
on her cell phone she was watching
amazing facts out in the jungle in the
middle of New Guinea and uh they were
watching there it's just amazing it's so
incredible so you know the Bible tells
us that Jesus in Revelation 14 chapter
14 of Revelation verse 14 it says Christ
comes in the clouds he's pictured before
Jesus comes in the clouds it depicts
these three Angelic messages that go to
the world and that's happening now and
maybe people would like to know what are
those messages the last messages that go
to the world before Jesus comes and you
find that in Revelation chapter 14 we
call it the Three Angels messages and
it's to the Everlasting gospel that has
to go to Every Nation K tongue and
people our study guide is called angel
messages from space and that is our free
offer for anyone who is watching or
listening just call the number 800 835
6747 and you can ask for offer number
1037 or ask for it by name it's called
angel messages from space you can also
dial pound 250 on your smartphone say
Bible ansers live and ask for it that
way called angel messages from space
probably one of the most most important
messages it's sort of God's last warning
message to the world you find it there
in Revelation chapter 14 well before we
go to the phone lines let's have a word
of prayer dear Father in heaven we thank
you once again for this opportunity to
open up your word and study and Lord we
always ask for your spirit to come and
guide us here in the studio and be with
those who are listening wherever they
might be in their car or at home and
lead us Lord into a clearer
understanding of Bible Truth for we ask
this in jesus' name amen amen our first
caller this evening is Gary listening in
Illinois Gary you are on Bible answers
live thank you I found two places in the
Bible where Armageddon could be
referenced Revelation 16 the kings of
the whole world are enticed by four
demonic angels uh when the Euphrates
River dries up and they're taken to the
place in the Hebrew called Armageddon
and then again in Revelation 20 um this
this is the second Resurrection the war
of the unrighteous dead uh once they
resurrect from the grave they attack New
Jerusalem and during the battle God
sends down fire and destroys them I
guess second death so which of these two
is the real
Armageddon are they both the same
Armageddon it doesn't seem like they
they are all right um first of all the
key to understanding Revelation chapter
16 where it talks about the Euphrates
River trying up to make way for the
kings of the East and these three
unclean spirits gather the Kings to
battle you go to the Old Testament and
King Saul goes to an evil spirit and he
then is killed in the battle the next
day now Saul had been trying to kill
David who was a type of Christ the
battle of Armageddon is principally a
battle between those who follow Christ
and those who follow the devil um and
you know even though King Saul was a Jew
he was killing the priests and and you
know sometimes the devil gets in into
the church that's going to happen in the
end where through the guise of
Christianity and false worship the devil
is going to bring about
persecution and Jesus said the day is
coming and this is I think John 16 Those
Who Kill you will think they're serving
God so the first stage of this battle
between Christ and Satan is taking place
prior to the second coming it's a war
the final battle of the war is when
Satan then tries to launch this final
desperate attack at the end so it's
really one Armageddon reaches across the
Millennium between two Wars yeah there
are two phases that the first phase
takes place at the second coming of
Christ and the wicked then die will we
called the first death right the second
part of the battle which takes place at
the end of the Thousand Years it says uh
death and hell and the devil and the
wicked are thrown into the Lake of Fire
and they are no more they are consumed
by those fires so that is the second
part of the battle of Armageddon which
is the final destruction of sin and
Sinners and the Earth is recreated after
that the Earth is purified by fire and
Revelation 21 talks about a new heavens
and a new Earth wherein dwells
righteousness that's right you know we
do have a study guide called a thousand
years of Peace it talks about what
happens at the end of that Thousand
Years we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800 835
6747 and you can ask for the study guide
It's called a thousand years of Peace
it's about Revelation chapter 20
otherwise known as the Millennium or you
can dial pound 250 on your smartphone
and just say Bible answers live and ask
for that study guide by name thank you
Gary we got Peggy listening in
Pennsylvania Peggy welcome to the
program I said Peggy is that how you say
it hi hi are you on the
air hi my name is pegy thank you for
answering my call yeah okay indulge me
for a couple of minutes if you
may I've read my entire Bible I've been
a Christian for a very long time mhm and
um unfortunately where I relocated my
myself um there's not reception of the
station of Christian that I used to
listen to so I found this other station
that is very liking to my ear until I
figure the type of denomination that
they are and also they speak a lot about
the Sabbath I do have quite a few
friends who practice or keep the Sabbath
because they are from that religion so
my question
is according to the Bible when I read it
when God was making
creation there was no man
around I don't recall reading anywhere
in the Bible where the days
were named like we know them to be now
human name the days the same way human
decide whenever they are in a particular
practice they don't like it they go out
and form their own other
Doctrine so how do we
know for I really am seeking for the
truth the more I'm my Bible the more I
want to see the truth and now there is
so much opinions so many books which
really I don't bother to read because
otherwise you become confused because
everybody have their own
opinions how
does human or people who are confessing
that the religion that they are that
that keep the Sabbath as God committed
to do was definitely on a Saturday all
right there's your question I I
appreciate that piggy um first of all
how do we know that uh the seventh day
is Saturday well first of all let's just
establish that uh I believe there are
good Christian people in many different
churches I'm not trying to condemn
anyone but if you want to know what the
Bible says is the truth uh very clearly
in creation you look in the the days of
the week are numbered they're not named
we didn't get the N the uh the names for
the days of the week until the Romans
you know we started adopting some of the
Roman names first day of the week they
call Sunday and it's Sunday is the first
day of the week it's when Jesus rose we
know what day it is it says and on the
first day of the week we know that he
was crucified uh it was a preparation
day which is what we call Friday which
is the sixth day of the week he rested
in the Tomb on the seventh day they
wanted to go home and prepare spices the
Bible tells us in Luke 23 and keep the
Sabbath according to the Commandment so
the day
between the sixth day and the first day
is the seventh day and he died on Friday
that's what we got Good Friday he rested
in the Tomb on the Sabbath he even kept
the Sabbath and his death he rose Sunday
morning and the first day of the week so
not only that but you've got a nation of
16 million Jews around the world many of
them still keep the seventh day of the
week which is Saturday so there's been
no confusion if you look in any
encyclopedia or dictionary and you just
type in first day of the week or Sunday
it'll tell you first day of the week so
there's no real confusion about that MH
and of course the fourth Commandment
which talks about the Sabbath it says
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God yeah so we know which day
of the week is the Sabbath it's the
seventh day and like you mentioned when
when Jesus was on the earth the Jews
were were keeping the seventh day they
called it the Sabbath Jesus kept the
Sabbath along with the rest of the
Jewish people and since then there's
been an accurate record of which day of
the week is the Sabbath which is the
seventh day yeah it's come all the way
down to our time it starts back in
Genesis 2 after God created man on the
sixth day and he said it was good says
and on the seventh day he ended his work
which he had done he rested the Sabbath
day seventh day he blessed the seventh
day and Jesus said Sabbath was made for
man so man is made the sixth day the
seventh day he makes the Sabbath for man
the word Jesus uses there is anthropos
it doesn't mean Jews it means Mankind
and you know man still needs that day of
rest and it's not any day God said I've
blessed a day a special day and I want
you to keep the day I blessed so that's
why you're hearing that and um we have a
whole website that can answer questions
as well as a study guide that's right we
have a website called sabbathtruth.com
and anyone can go to it take a look at
it there videos a lot of Bible study
material we also have one of our amazing
fact study guides it's called The Lost
day of history and it's about the
Sabbath and we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800 835
6747 just ask for that study guide It's
called The L day of history or you can
dial pound 250 and say Bible answers
live and then ask for it by name the
last day of History thank you piggy we
got Glenn listening in Ohio Glenn
welcome to the
program thank you good evening and thank
you for taking my call yes sir you know
my question could probably better be
stated is xoch really still
alive when my mother passed I was there
and her passing was very quiet and
restful I believe she was an example of
what the Bible says did not see death
could that that those wording could that
apply to the fact that Enoch died as in
according to Hebrews 11 1113 that he he
really died but he didn't see death
that's my question all right um you know
the Bible I think is pretty clear in
Hebrews 11 it it's telling us that uh
you know Enoch was not for God took him
and he had this testimony uh he walked
with God and
so the Bible I think is indicating that
Enoch did not die now we're very haul
happy and thankful for those that have a
peaceful death and they are resting in
Jesus and that's why you've got
cemeteries that say rip rest in peace
that's what the Lord wants for his uh
children sleeping that dreamless
peaceful sleep there's no consciousness
of time their next conscious thought if
they die saved is be in the first
resurrection and then in Christ will
rise the next thing they see after death
is the face of their savior which is a
beautiful thought but Enoch never did
die God translated him he did not die
and get resurrected God just has gave
him a glorified body so what happened to
Enoch is what's happening to the people
who are alive when Jesus comes and
Pastor Ross I think it's 1 Corinthians
15 where he said that in a moment the
twinkling of an eye at the last Trump we
are transformed this Mortal puts on
immortality so we don't die those who
are alive and remain when the Lord comes
says we're caught up to meet the
resurrected Saints in the air and that's
what happened to Enoch and Elijah and
I'm hoping that's my experience I mean
if I have to die first so be it but I'd
like to avoid it if I can the verse
you're referring to there Pastor D 1
Corinthians chapter 15 53- 54 yeah the
whole chapter is on the resurrection
thank you so much we appreciate that uh
Glenn next caller that we have is James
in Tennessee James welcome to the
program hey good afternoon y'all U I was
just going to ask my question is based
on Acts 4:12 all throughout the Bible
ible it says those who have not denied
my name well it says that in Revelation
The Book of Malachi talks about his name
a lot Acts 4:12 says there's only one
name given amongst men where you must be
saved now we know back in the Scrolls
there wasn't like you said vs or
consonant they would either call him you
know yahusha or Yeshua you know so the
letter J I found out has only been
around for about 6 or 700 years so if
the Bible was you God's word was written
so long ago how did they throw the name
j and how can we call him Jesus if the
letter J is only been around six or 700
years wouldn't that be breaking like the
Commandment there shall have no other
gods before me because the name Jesus
was not in the Scrolls so you're talking
about I want to make sure I'm doing it
in Truth you know I just want to worship
spirit and Truth in Acts 4:12 say
there's only one name given amongst men
where we must be saved right it kind of
scares me because there was no J in
Hebrew so I don't you know kind of like
the Sabbath tried to change the Sabbath
from Saturday to Sunday and I just want
that to be God's Authority go ahead okay
yeah I I understand where you're coming
from so the the question you're really
asking is if people are using the
pronunciation of Jesus instead of yua or
Yahweh to talk to God are they somehow
disobeying am I saying that
correctly MH yeah well if does god
require us to pronounce his name in the
original Hebrew or does he expect us to
pronounce his name in our native tongues
so if I'm in Mexico and they don't say
Jesus they say
Jesus and uh in some countries it's Jew
uh you know and if I was in Israel it
would be Yeshua so I don't know that God
is requiring us to speak in the original
language when we say his name we can say
the translated version of his name and
in you know the American culture and a
lot of English languages that's come
across as Jesus if a person feels
convicted that they're somehow losing
power by not pronouncing it correctly
then they should you know pronounce it
as close to the original Hebrew as they
think but I don't think I'd put that on
other people uh cuz you know we we speak
to God God is the one who confus the
languages we speak to him our native
tongues and yeah let me add you know the
verse that you're looking at there is no
other name given among men whereby we
must be saved the word then name means
the Savior means Jesus we are not saved
by a name we are saved by a person and
we refer to that person by a name now
that name might be pronounced
differently in different languages but
it's referring to the same person right
and I think that's the point of the
verse there is one that saves us and
that's Jesus he's the Savior now if
you're speaking Spanish how
right but it's the same person that
we're referring to we're talking about
Jesus so I don't think the Bible is
saying we all need to speak Hebrew but
we all saved by the same person meaning
the savior Christ with Jesus the
emphasis is the character the
relationship person not how you move
your tongue right and and pronounce it
so I hope that helps a little bit James
and absolutely there is no other name
given among men whereby we must be saved
than Christ the Messiah you want to say
Yeshua
or Jesus um it's the same individual
depends on what tongue you speak and
even the Bible writers themselves they
didn't always use the exact same name
when referring to Christ sometimes the
Messiah sometimes Christ go to
Revelations he's got 20 names that's
right the Alpha and the Omega right so
different names that's right all right
we got John listening in New York John
welcome to the
program yes good even happy New Year by
the way thank you you're on the air how
can we help you yes uh Pastor Doug um I
really have two questions can I ask my
two questions let's start one at a
time okay thank you um um my first
question is um I go to church on Sunday
which is called Resurrection Day correct
yeah he did rise on Sunday
correct okay so why am I going to church
on Sunday
then well do you have a command anywhere
in scripture to go to Church on the
first day of the
week not that I know of but but but the
seventh day was the old um um what's
that word I'm looking for I can't think
the old old covenant thank you right
yeah and that that was crucified at the
cross and then the the New Covenant uh
doesn't say uh go to church on Sunday
but that's why do they worship for going
on Sunday resur rection well let's talk
about that John for a second um you know
what the Ten Commandments are right I
know but that's the old Covenant well
let's let's just bear with me for a
second so the Commandment that says
Don't murder is that the old Covenant or
are we still supposed to keep that no
that one you keep yes what about the
Commandment say don't commit
adultery yeah so you you would agree
with all of the Ten Commandments except
the
fourth no the fourth one was Ellen G
white who was the founder and somebody
no Ellen G white did not write the Ten
Commandments I know but she founded she
founded the uh the the ministry that I'm
talking about but anyway the fourth
Commandment mean says for worship on the
Sabbath yeah the fourth Commandment says
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
so it's the one Commandment that God
says to
remember and Jesus as his custom was and
we're a Christian as a follower of
Christ as his custom was he it says he
went into the synagogue on the Sabbath
day and Paul as his custom was and so
there's no question that all the way
from the time of Adam through the
children of Israel through the New
Testament God they believed in keeping
the Ten Commandments now the Sabbath we
believe in all of them we don't believe
in one more than the other we just think
you need to be consistent and keep them
all so I think that was your first
question what was your second question
John because we're running up against
our break
here okay my second question is I'm
blind and the the uh that God says that
when he comes with Jesus that every eye
will see him and if I'm blind how do I
do that well you know what I think that
blind people are going to be healed to
see the coming of the Lord and uh how
God does that I don't know but I have no
doubt in my mind that uh he's he's going
to help them be able to recognize that
especially Believers because it says
that his coming it says this Mortal must
put on immortality so we get Immortal
glorified bodies at that
time well I hope that helps a little bit
John now we do have a study guide on
your first question about uh it's
actually a book we'll share with you and
it's called um uh does God's grace blot
out the law I had to think about it
talks about the covenants does God's
grace blot out the law so tells you the
difference between the new and the old
covenants and you that's a great book
Pastor D we don't always give it away so
we want to encourage you to take
advantage of it it's called does God's
grace blot out the law and it really
deals with the subject gives a lot of
excellent Bible text talk about the New
Covenant the old Covenant to get that
just call 800 83567 47 and you can ask
for the book it's called does God's
grace blot out the law you can also dial
pound 250 on your smartphone and ask for
Bible answers live and then of course
you can ask for that book by name does
God's grace blot out the LW you Pastor D
we're looking at the uh the program
breaking coming up here and we might not
have time to take another caller but we
are going to continue with additional
programs but you know I know this is
early but maybe we'll just get it out
there I was thinking about it because
John called us from New York later this
year we actually going to be in New York
for a Bible seminar and we're going to
get the word out even early that's right
so friends mark it on your calendar
amazing facts is going to the Big Apple
we're going to Manhattan and it will be
September 20 through October 5 we were
there 25 years ago in the Manhattan
Center we're going back to the Manhattan
Center that was a a wonderful experience
and that was called the Millennium of
Prophecy this event is called prophecy
Odyssey and not only will we be
broadcasting around the country and
around the world but uh we're inviting
people who want to join us and be
missionaries in Manhattan give out
literature and to um you know do some
Street Ministry then come to the
meetings at night it's going to be a
really exciting time it's going to also
be just before what is probably going to
be a very interesting election coming up
so if you want to be part of something
historic friends then you may want to go
to New York City you look online and you
can I think our website's up it's still
under construction but if you look under
prophecy Odyssey Mark those dates on
your calendar and you might want to know
how do I download the lessons and learn
these learn about the final events of
Prophecy the time we're living in now uh
you'll be really blessed by that that's
right we can to have a brand new set of
lessons is going to be going through
these various TRS and I think it's a
total of 14 presentations in all and
it's going to be every night except I
think one night a week we can have off
and as you mentioned the Manhattan
Center we were there just not long ago
past today we did sort of a previsit and
what a place you you right down the
street from the Empire State Building
you can actually see it from the
Manhattan Center yeah and then just a
little way down you got um Grand Central
State or Pen Station yeah Penn Station
but then there's also that big Madison
Square Madison Square Gardens that's
right it's right there b camera shop
that's right that's where all our media
everything crowded right there in that
part of of Manhattan so plan to be there
it'll be a very exciting event that's
taking place yeah and you may want to
host one of these in your home people
are going to open their homes and their
churches invite their friends over turn
on the presentation anywhere in the
world it'll be translated into Spanish
English well it won't be translated
Spanish English French Portuguese
Russian Hindi and I'm sure I've left
some things out so find out all you can
about the prophecy Odyssey and you want
to put that on your calendar and plan on
bringing your friends there I'm trying
to find a way to tread water for 10 more
seconds I just totally ran out of things
to say hey we got more questions coming
friends so just stay with us we'll be
back in two minutes and take more Bible
questions stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
[Music]
shortly
the US government is drowning in debt to
the tune of$ 22 trillion but before you
wag your finger at the government's
spending the Federal Reserve says the
average American household carries over
$137,000 in debt well it was never God's
plan that we live with a burden of debt
Proverbs 22:7 warns us the rich rules
over the poor and the borrower is
servant to the lender living with debt
is a stressful burden that actually
hurts your relationship with God in my
new pocketbook deliverance from debt I
outline the Bible principles on how to
properly manage your money with some
practical suggestions and how you can
get out and stay out of debt if you or
someone you love is drowning in debt
order a copy of Deliverance from debt
today it can be a lifesaver to keep you
from going under please call
85387 275 or visit AF bookstore.com
thank you for tuning in to amazing facts
have you ever wanted to study the
teachings of the Bible in an easy to
understand stepbystep way the amazing
facts Bible school offers free simple to
follow lessons that will guide you
through all of the vital teachings of
scripture visit amazing bibl studies.com
to sign up for your free lessons they're
available by mail or online studies are
also offered in multiple languages
Jerusalem the city of Peace has been a
place of unending Conflict for centuries
many now believe that Jerusalem will
soon take Center Stage again but what
does the Bible say the fall and Rise of
Jerusalem presents the vital history you
need to know about Jerusalem and its
role in Endtime Bible prophecy this
amazing facts edition of the classic
volume the great controversy is the
perfect sharing book get your copy at AF
bookstore.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today if you have a question about the
Bible or living the Christian Life call
us now at 800 God says that's 800 463
7297 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live it is a live
International interactive Bible study we
invite you to join in you can call in
with your questions 800 God says we have
operators standing by and lines open if
you want to uh call in your Bible
question we'll do our best to answer it
in about 3 minutes per call we try to
roughly budget that to get as many as we
can we're also streaming on television
you can watch it on AFV on Good News
Network where um you may be seeing a
replay on Three Angels
Broadcasting and uh Facebook amazing
facts what did I forget YouTube anyway
we're trying to get the word out I'm
Doug Bachelor my name is John Ross and
we have Julian who's listening in
Illinois Julian welcome to Bible answers
live Hi how are you guys doing well
thank
you any question in yeah oh okay um so
in Genesis 2818 it describes Jacob
building a pillar to honor God but in
Deuteronomy 16:22 it says not to build
any sacred pillars which God hates and
that's probably due to the Canaanite
culture and I just want to know what the
difference between Jacob's intentions
were and what would stop someone from
building them today yeah yeah yeah
you're very sharp that you caught that
but actually they're talking about two
different things the word is the same
Jacob basically takes the stone that he
used as a pillow and it may have been a
little bit of a a longer Stone and he
set it up so you know if the stone is
flat you know it's been it's naturally
knocked down by erosion but he wanted to
remember the spot and so he he kind of
raised it up so he'd remember this
location put some oil on it and named it
bethl that was very different from when
the the Canaanites would their pillars
were actually
carved and they often had sexual
anotations and they were all these um
rituals and things were obscene uh and
that was very common in a lot of the
cultures not only among the Canaanites
you go to Central South America you can
see a lot of the same thing this is what
he's talking about in Deuteronomy it
wasn't Jacob just setting up an uncarved
Stone and saying I don't want to forget
this spot because you see when the
children of Israel crossed the Jordan
River they took 12 Stones Out of the
river and they made an altar they used
12 instead of one so they used to make
stone memorials to remember events but
they the key is Moses said You shall not
lift up your tool upon it as soon as
they started carving it he says you do
that you polluted it and that's why
Elijah rebuilt the altar of the Lord he
took the stones this that's why it says
in Daniel 2 a stone cut without man's
hands meaning it's not an idol like the
statue so good catch Julian I hope that
makes sense there are two different
things that are happen there okay thank
you we've got Irene listening in
California Irene welcome to the
program hi good evening
evening so I would like to ask you to
help settle an argument we had about the
week of creation um we know Adam was
made on the sixth day was it's a
two-part question actually was um Eve
made later on this day and when did they
get married was it before Sabbath after
Sabbath how does that go yeah well as
near as we can tell a lot happened on
the sixth day you know when God creates
all the the land animals he speaks them
into existence God doesn't have to form
them one by one and he doesn't have to
form a million of each he just has to do
two so God forms the animals and then he
as then he forms man he breathes into
him the dust of uh the breath of life
and makes him from the dust of the Earth
and then Adam is made he comes out of
the factory you know you can buy a
computer all you got to do is plug it in
and all the programs are running
software was installed he knew how to
walk and talk when God made him and God
said you know name the animals and he
notices that all the animals have
partners and he realize something's
missing God wanted him to sense that
need so then still on the sixth day when
God yeah Adam's naming all the animals
we think that he had to name you know
10,000 Zoological species he's naming
the main categories of animal animals
and that that day then God puts him to
sleep takes his Reb makes a woman
presents her to Adam God is basically
performing The Wedding they didn't
invite all the guests and have cake the
the wedding is when he presents Eve to
Adam and the Bible says that God did one
funeral it was for Moses and he does one
wedding it was for Adam so um they were
both made the six day is that your
understanding past I think so absolutely
so like you say Not only was uh Adam
created on the sixth day he named the
animals then he goes to sleep and a
surgery takes place God takes out a rib
and then you know forms Eve and then
brings the two together and then
together as a couple they welcoming the
Sabbath the day of rest yeah you know
and I just heard recently that uh
they're finding out from within the
bones you get the stem cells that are
just you know the most powerful cells
and they' got the DNA and everything and
so it actually makes more sense when you
study it why you take a rib anyway you
had a second part to that question if
I'm not
mistaken well that was the second part
was did they and Dr or part um Pastor
Ross just answered it it was the wedding
was done when he brought them together
and it was done before Sabbath so man
and female and the wedding or the
marriage part was all done before in the
week of creation all done before Sabbath
was created on the seventh day that's
what we were arguing because my son was
like well don't argue
like good argument though I don't want
to take
sides yeah so that was Sabbath was their
honeymoon if you think about it they
spent time with God in the garden
blessing yeah well God bless thank you
for your question next caller that we
have is Steve in Idaho Steve welcome to
Bible aners
live thank you good evening pastors I
just wanted to thank you for taking my
call and this resource my question is
regarding uh Deuteronomy 14 and verse 26
I've looked into some different Bible
commentaries I understand most of it but
I guess I'm just not understanding why
it's in regards to tithing really and I
guess I just don't understand um verse
26 is really throwing me with um strong
drink all right well for let me read it
for our friends that are listening now
this is talking about when they would go
up to these annual feasts they not all
of the
uh the feast days that they actually
gather together for a convocation but
there were I think three annual feasts
where they would go up and during these
feasts um they had a second tithe part
of that second tithe was it says you can
and let me read it uh Deuteronomy
chapter 14:26 and you'll spend that
money for whatever your heart desires
he's talking about the second tithe for
oxen or sheep for wine or similar drink
for whatever your heart desires you
shall eat it before the Lord your God
and rejoice you and in the household so
there was a feast it was like a vacation
Feast a tithe that they would set aside
and that was to be used towards um
worshiping God now when it says strong
drink the word strong drink there if you
look in the new King James it just says
similar
drink and they basically uh they could
concentrate wine and because it was
concentrated it would transport better
was an alcoholic because you know the
Bible says other places wine is a mocker
strong drink is Raging and who has
wounds who has woe who has redness of
eyes those that car at the wine so U two
kinds of wine described in the Bible
you've got your fermented and your
unfermented and it is interesting pad
you mentioned that they had a way of
actually preserving grape juice where
they would be able to boil it or someh
get it to a thick syrupy type of of
paste and then you'd add water to it and
mix it and dilute it and it was still
fresh and it would keep a lot longer
yeah and uh so they had different ways
of doing that easier to transport and
then that have it throughout the year
yeah exactly and they've actually found
a lot of the uh vessels and earns that
they used to keep these these aoras of
wine in them so hope that helps a little
bit Lee or sorry that was Steve Steve
and I thank you pre by the way I've got
a book I wrote and it's called alcohol
and the Christian and it talks about
this passage alcohol and the Christian
will send you a free copy and the number
to call for that is 8835 6747 and again
the book is called alcohol and the
Christian also if you'd like to receive
a digital version of that just out pound
250 say Bible answers live and ask for
the book it's called alcohol and the
Christian and we will send it to you
next call is Lee in Texas Lee welcome to
the
program yes thank you for having me
again I have a one question and and one
more question that that's a true or
false question hopefully you can answer
both
okay okay my first my first question is
is are the seven trumpets past current
or future events because I know they're
not the plagues right that's simple
enough well the seven trumpets cover a
military history of the church between
the first coming and the second coming
so they're not all past but we're we're
living in them we believe in what they
call the
historic uh view of Prophecy that
prophecy a lot of people think
Revelation is written for the last 10
minutes of time Revelation was written
from the time of John to cover the
history of the church between the first
coming and the second coming you got the
Seven Seals are talking about the
political history if you will you've got
the seven trumpets are more of like a
military history the seven churches give
a spiritual history of the church from
the first to the second coming we're
living in the age of
leoda and what was your second question
you
said yes my second question is um I've
been doing doing some research on the
ephes river that's been drying up
recently yeah and even though it's
drying up right now and I know it's part
of the also the seven last plagues but
if the River dries up before the seven
last plagues begin does that have
specific
meaning you know the it is true that the
sixth plague in Revelation 16 talks
about the Euphrates drying up I think
that's one of the plagues I believe all
the plagues have a literal application I
think there's really going to be blood
and boils it's going to be terrible
that's why it says it's a time of
trouble such as there never has been but
I think the emphasis of the sixth plague
is on more than just the river I think
it's talking about a point in history
when the Euphrates dried up when the
children of Israel were captives in
Babylon it's signal that they were going
to go to the promised land because
Babylon fell and you read in Revelation
it talks about Babylon falling in
chapter 18 and 19 and so I think the
sixth plague is overlapping that
when the The Source the power of the
Euphrates river to supply life to
Babylon was dried up all right thank you
Lee we've got Michael in Texas Michael
welcome to the
program Michael you there yeah
hi yes good evening pastors and Shalom
to you all uh I wonder if you could give
me a quick explanation of the sin and to
death in 1 John
5:16 all right Pastor Ross I've been
hogging the time you want to go after
that let me read it for you 1 John 5:16
it says if anyone sees his brother
sinning a sin which does not lead to
death he will ask and he will give him
life uh For Those who commit sin not
leading to death so here it talks about
something called a sin that does not
lead to death what is that sin well I
think first of all it might be a sin of
ignorance if somebody does not realize
that they are uh sinning and you bring
that to their attention then they're
aware of it uh there is another sin that
all also is the unpardonable sin or that
is the sin against the Holy Spirit and
that is somebody is grieved away the
Holy Spirit and they have no desire for
repentance and have no desire to turn
from the sin well then any sin could in
essence lead to death if we rebel
against the promptings of the Holy
Spirit but you know the Bible says there
are those who sin not knowingly and if
you see somebody sinning and you bring
it to their attention hopefully they'll
realize and you can share with them the
scriptures and if they repent they can
be forgiven it's sin that does not lead
to death but if it is not repented of or
if somebody Rebels to it or that's a
different story that's right you know we
do have a book it's called the
unpardonable sin talks about the it's
called Beyond Mercy what is the
unpardonable sin mer that's right and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks the number for that
is 800 835
6747 you can ask for the book it's
called Beyond Mercy or D pound 250 on
your smartphone just say Bible answers
live and then ask for it by name thank
you Michael we've got Peter in New
Jersey Peter welcome to the program
thank you good evening gentlemen and uh
we listen on wmca out of New York City
by the way oh wonderful en Joy yes I
some time ago I I became a vegetarian um
based on Genesis and and also the health
evidence of today in today's world they
do seem to indicate that uh they're in
line with the biblical view of uh the
health benefits of being a vegetarian
and I just wanted to ask you guys I know
you guys are vegans or vegetarians would
you consider um would Dairy and eggs be
in line with the Bible uh as being in
that vegetarian group all right well
first let's and by the way I hope you
heard the announcement we'll be in New
York City and and tell your friends and
enemies to come join us on at the
Manhattan Center September 20 to October
5 um there's no scripture that commands
vegetarianism I want to be real clear
about that the script scriptures do
teach this was God's original ideal
meaning Adam and Eve you know that was
the original diet and again when we get
to the new Earth we'll all be V we're
not going to chase down and kill animals
there there's no death no more pain so
it's obviously the better design and as
you mentioned the jury is in that
there's no question that vegetarianism
is going to improve whatever Health you
have uh even people fighting cancer have
found that they respond much better to
treatment if they're being careful about
their diet the fewer animal products you
eat the less disease you'll have now
that doesn't mean that milk or I'm a
vegan vegetarian and it's not a
religious thing for me it's just I'm
allergic to milk I don't I think Pastor
Ross is a vegetarian vegetarian and uh
probably vegan most of the time H yeah
mostly vegan but you know eggs is one of
those categories that uh you know
sometimes people need to eat it if
they're not getting enough protein but
typically the vegetarian diet today if
you eat a well balanced diet you've got
everything you need a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich if you got good jelly and
good peanut butter has got your fruits
grains and nuts and protein everything
is in there
B12 and that's how we survived our youth
is peanut butter and CH I wasn't even a
vegetarian back then so it's yeah it's
not hard I've been a vegetarian for well
you all your life huh I've been a
vegetarian for over 40 years and uh yeah
we had a good game of ret ball today we
did with our boys it was fun yeah we
kept up with our boys so so uh yeah we
highly recommend it but I just want to
be clear the Bible doesn't command
vegetarianism it is preferable and it's
uh you'll be blessed if you do if you're
going to eat meat the Bible does say you
shouldn't eat the unclean meats and we
have a lesson on that Pastor Ross we do
it's called God's free health plan and
you know that's exactly what it is what
does the Bible say about your health
what can you eat what you should not eat
well be Happ to send it to anyone who
calls and asks the number is 800 835
6747 you can ask for that study guide
It's called God's free health plan or
doll pound 250 on your smartphone and
just say Bible answers live we'll be
happy to get that to you that's a
digital version if you do the pound 250
next caller that we have is uh EF Frank
listening in New York EF Frank welcome
to the program yeah thank you very much
uh Pastor Ross and uh Pastor Doug I have
a question that I need to ask because
it's uh a question that involves uh an
encounter that I had uh several years
ago uh this has to do with a a being
that approached me I don't know if it
was the green reaper it was some spirit
with a brown cape and a a bald head and
would um denounce me and say to me that
uh my father will die of a heart attack
eventually because uh I got in a way of
uh defending a major um uh Italian Crime
Boss of a major New York uh City crime
family and it the spirit would appear to
at my door and threaten my father all
the time and he actually died two years
ago of a heart attack at the same time I
also was approached by a Spirit uh of a
deceased uh relative of a former mayor
of the city of New York and uh one day
that Spirit uh attacked me in my
apartment and launched me into my wall
so Pastor dou and pastor
uh Bachelor I want to ask you this um
this second Spirit um said that because
I went involuntarily to the Stanley
Hotel in es Park Colorado in 1974 and I
did speak to Stephen King on October
30th 1974 and then 1991 and
1995 the spirit of the of Jimmy Walker's
uh dead relative followed me up to my
home
and in the Bible it says that unclean
spirits and evil spirits can be rebuked
through uh prayer and meditation and
fasting but mostly through prayer uh can
you answer the this question can you
actually rebuke Spirits through Reading
scripture and and telling them to stay
away from you and rebuke them that way
because I have no recourse in calling uh
a minister of the of the cloth or any
other type of clergy to assist me with
what happened to me okay well yeah let
me get to the the heart of your question
first of all you don't have to be a
pastor to pray that a person might be
delivered uh Jesus said in Mark 16 these
signs will follow them that believe he
didn't say these signs will follow the
pastors and so Believers and you don't
want to be you know getting involved
into a lot of
spiritualism uh you know Bible tells in
Acts
I think it's chapter 13 the sons of ska
tried to cast out a devil they didn't
really know the Lord they had no
relationship with the Lord and this
demon-possessed man beat them up said I
know Jesus and I know Paul but I don't
know you so if you're going to be
praying that a person is delivered Jesus
said some cases are difficult and they
only come out through prayer and fasting
but he did make it clear through prayer
through faith through fasting and
claiming the name of the Lord that uh we
could see people delivered from the
Devil because in reality every time you
preach the gospel and a person accepts
Jesus they are being delivered from the
devil to some extent there's just
varying degrees of captivity you might
say but everybody that hears the gospel
and accepts it the power of the word
takes from from Darkness to light and so
um closer you are of the Lord uh and the
more faith uh I think that it's easier
for you to deal with more difficult
cases there are varying degrees Jesus
had that man that had a whole Legion of
demons sometimes just one so hope that
helps e Frank it sounds like you've had
an interesting experience but don't
don't be reading Stephen King's books
anymore all right next caller that we
have is Francisco in Oregon Francisco
welcome to the
program hi um it's a pleasure first of
all to be on live with you um with you
guys especially a bachelor um I'm a big
fan so I have a question um so I've been
s Venice for 14 years my life I'm 26
years old and um I'm concerned of um how
um the Seven Day Adventist we do not
believe um with talking talking in
tongues nor dancing you know um the
whole nine yards of that nature and I'm
just wondering why well there two
different things you're talking about
there you know one what does the Bible
say and the interesting thing for me is
not what a church teaches but what does
the Bible say uh the Bible teaches that
um speaking in tongues I believe in
speaking in tongues and I believe in the
gift of tongues and uh I will probably
be in Pakistan later this year if a war
doesn't break out and I'll need a
translator who has the gift of tongues
to speak both English and u
u and then be in uh India where I'll
need a person with a gift of tongues
that can speak Tamil and English and
we'll be in Jakarta where they need to
speak Bahasa Indonesia
and English and all these people will
have the gift of tongues on the day of
Pentecost God poured out his spirit and
gave the disciples the supernatural
ability to speak in the languages of the
Jews that were visiting that day from
around the Roman Empire that is a gift
of tongues we believe in the gift of
tongues for every truth of God there's a
counterfeit and a lot of churches are
are practicing a counterfeit version of
this so to to just tie off that first
part of the question um
Francisco we have a book called
understanding tongues we will send you a
free copy uh of that book but just you
asked about dancing the Bible does not
forbid biblical dancing if you're
dancing like Mariam and David um th
those were you know a person can be
filled with the spirit and is a leap for
Joy um the syncopated sexually
suggestive dancing is inappropriate for
a Christian and that's what happens in
most dance clubs
you just have to ask yourself would
Jesus do this that's a Christian so
that's a different subject but how do
they get that book on tongues number to
call is 8835 6747 you can ask for the
book it's called understanding tongues
I'll be able to send it to anyone who
calls and ask you can also dial pound
250 say Bible answers live and then ask
for that book it's a digital version
we'll send it to you understanding
tongues all right we got time maybe for
one or two more we've got let's see uh
Tom is listening in Washington Tom
welcome to the
program hi Pastor John Pastor Doug hey
thanks for calling Tom Andy my question
is about the second death and I'm just
curious if that's a literal fire because
I'm just wondering if angels are
susceptible to the fire as we know it I
just wonder yeah that is a good question
well it's it's probably not the kind of
Hickory fire you would use in a barbecue
this is a fire of God so I think you're
right that it it may even be different
than the fire that came down on Sodom
and Gomorrah but because it's a fire
that does not burn them
immediately some will suffer different
intensities and different lengths
depending on what their sins are
ultimately it says the fire comes down
from heaven and devours or consumes them
so we're not going to be looking out of
our windows from the New Jerusalem and
watching people Blister in the Flames
but yeah it may be the fire that comes
from God you know the Bible talks about
that our God is a consuming fire his
presence his glory his brightness there
may be some heat think more like
lightning as opposed to um a bonfire and
something else about this fire is it
says it consumes the devil and his
angels yeah these are Spirit beings so
they probably don't get affected by heat
the way we do so it is something
different it's a judgment fire it's a
judgment fire a different kind of fire
you know we do have a study God is
called is the devil in charge of hell it
talks about the destruction of the
wicked the second death at the end of
the 10,000 years we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and asks again
that number is 800 835 6747 you can ask
the study guide is the devil in charge
of Hell or just dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live and
then you can ask for it by name is the
devil in charge of hell and we've got a
website it's called hell truth.com you
can go there right away and you can read
the lesson there you can also watch some
videos and just look at some great Bible
studies on the subject amen oh 33
seconds I tell you what friends uh for
those listening in case you don't know
we're going to say goodbye to our
friends that are listening on satellite
these landbased stations operate on a
different clock so we kind of sign off
in two stages for the rest of you if you
stay by we always do our best to do some
rapid fire Bible answers for those who
have emailed in questions for all the
rest God bless we'll study his word with
you again next week and um
yeah keep your eyes fixed on Jesus and
visit the amazingfacts.org website we'll
be right
back thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing fact
International a faith-based Ministry
located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back to your email questions if you'd
like to send us a email question the
email address is BS questions at
amazingfacts.org BL a sorry B Bible
answers live B questions at
amazingfacts.org Pastor Doug Tiffany is
asking is it okay to lend to people your
tithes if you do not have any cash to
lend them well there's a misnomer in the
question it says your tithe tithe is
actually something that belongs to God
the Bible says it's holy unto the Lord
and so you're kind of asking the
question is it okay to lend God's tithe
to someone else it's always easy to lend
someone else's money that's called
government that's what they do but no I
think that that that belongs to the Lord
and we shouldn't be lending that to
other people uh there is a second tithe
that they would give to the poor during
the feast sometimes that's a whole
different question though but your first
10% that really Belongs to the Lord and
is designated for the proclamation of
the Gospel okay we have uh Lena from New
Zealand asking is it all right to read
The Book of
Enoch yeah The Book of Enoch is what
they call an apocryphal book it is
interesting it's a wonderful work of
poetry it's got some things in there
that are theologically bizarre it was
not written by Enoch the book doesn't
appear in Jewish history until the time
of the Babylonian captivity there's no
reference to it so it was written by
probably a very devout Jew there's some
good information in there just don't
look at it as scripture uh Jude does
quote from The Book of Enoch and of
course Paul even quotes from from Greek
poets because there was certain phrases
he said this is an inspired phrase but
um The Book of Enoch is not scripture
okay we have uh Judy asking what does
the bible mean when it says and as many
as have been appointed to eternal life
believed does that mean that God chooses
who's saved and who's
lost no God gives everybody a free
choice but God knows everything and he
knows ahead of time how people are going
to choose but he's given them freedom to
choose when they choose they're called
appointed it means those who he knew
would choose they are appointed unto
everlasting life and so no we don't
believe in what they would call
predestination meaning that God looks
down and says I think I'll make some
people and Destroy them and then I'll
make some and save them God makes
everybody free and then he says
whosoever will let him take the Water of
Life freely Jesus tells us John 3:16
whosoever believes in Him friend you are
a whosoever anyone out there listening
you can believe that's why we do this
program God bless we will study his word
with you again next week and in the
meantime stay close to
Jesus Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
questions